So the five point plan,
the first of our five points
will be to end the abuse of the health and care visa.
We will stop overseas care workers
from bringing family dependents
and we will require care firms in England
to be regulated by the Care Quality Commission
in order for them to sponsor visas.
Approximately 120,000 dependents
accompanied 100,000 care workers
and senior care workers in the year
ending September 2023.
Only 25% of defendant dependents
are estimated to be in work,
meaning a significant number
or drawing on public services
rather than helping to grow the economy.
We recognise,
we recognise that farm workers do great work
in our NHS and health sector,
but it is also important
that migrants make a big enough financial contribution.
Therefore, we will increase
annual immigration health surcharge this year by 66%
from £624 to £1,035
to raise on average around £1.3 billion
for the health services of this country
every year. Second,
we will stop immigration
undercutting the salary of British workers.
We will increase the skilled worker earnings threshold
by a third to 38,700 from next spring
in line with the medium
full term wage for those kinds of jobs.
Those coming on health and social care visa routes
will be exempt
so we can continue to bring in the healthcare workers
on which our care sector and NHS rely.
Thirdly, we will scrap,
cut price shortage labour from overseas
by ending the 20% going rate salary discount
for shortage occupations.
And reforming the shortage occupation list.
I have asked the Migration Advisory Committee
to review the occupations on this list
because of our new
higher skilled worker salary threshold.
And we will create a new immigration salary list
with a reduced number of uh
occupations.
People only bring dependents
who they can support financially
by raising the minimum income for family visas
to the same threshold
as the minimum salary threshold for skills workers,
38,700. The minimum income requirement
of 18,600 has not been increased since 2012.
Madam Deputy Speaker,
this package of measures will take place
from next spring. Finally,
having already banned overseas master's students
from bringing family members to the UK,
I have asked
the Migration Advisory Committee
to review the graduate route
to prevent abuse.
To protect the integrity and quality
of the UK's
outstanding higher education sector,
it needs to work
in the best interests of the UK,
supporting the pathway into high
quality jobs
for the global talent pool,
but reducing opportunities for abuse.